bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france on voit que la
colère elle gronde aux etats-unis après
plusieurs décès qui implique des
policiers est ce qu'il faut craindre un
embrasement comme l'année dernière lors
du décès de georgia flight et ça n'est
pas impossible parce que évidemment
comme vous l'avez rappelé et plusieurs
cas et les assassinats d'afro américains
et dans le cas de ce jeune adolescent
latinos sont hyper fréquement il faut
savoir qu'il ya un problème structurel
la police aux états unis qui tue à peu
près 1000 personnes un peu plus de 1000
personnes chaque année
alors que les chypre la grande-bretagne
c'est quelque chose comme 16 ou 17 rk
secrètement et problèmes de
fonctionnement la police quelques rares
mais qu'un équipement militaire et par
là dessus il ya des problèmes évidemment
de racisme donc c'est quelque chose qui
peut exploser
comme l'année dernière alors joe biden
que peut-il faire concrètement pour
faire face à cette situation
cela fait que quelques mois qu'il dirige
maintenant les états unis est ce qu'on
peut lui imputer ce contexte là
aujourd'hui il est difficile d'imputer
au président ce qui est du ressort des
états voir des villes et les problèmes
de fonctionnement de la police sont très
fréquents dans de multiples endroits aux
états unis qui sont gérées localement ce
que le président peut faire ce qu'avait
fait obama
ces déclarations c'est de la rhétorique
mais il a essayé de
d'interdire et les armes fabriquées de
façon artisanale
mais il ya un lobby tellement fort aux
états unis qui circulent environ 400
millions d'armes
y a plus d'armes en circulation qui n'a
tué américain c'est un problème qui ne
peut pas être résolue tant qu'ils
rentrent en dames articulations et tant
qu'il y aura des forces politiques qui
sont en faveur de la vente d'armes
il ya des possibilités à la marge de
réduction mais le deuxième amendement
qui est interprété maintenant parce que
c'est relativement raison récents comme
le droit de porter une arme à deux des
défenseurs très important la cour
suprême détenus par les supp des
conservateurs donc il a une marge de
manoeuvre qui est étroite marge de
manoeuvre étroite on parler de la
prolifération des armes on va parler de
ce qui s'est passé juste tout à l'heure
à indianapolis mais s'agissant
précisément des violences policières des
accusations de racisme au sein de la
police que peut-il faire joe biden
aujourd'hui alors là le monopole de la
parole
il peut intervenir pour réclamer des
sanctions plus lourdes mais les
sanctions sont imposées par les jurys
locaux et l'histoire montre que très
souvent les meurtriers de deux jeunes en
général noir ne sont pas punis il ya une
longue liste de dejean afro américains
qui ont été tuées en général de jeunes
hommes et les policiers qui en sont
responsables ne sont pas tués et ça
c'est le résultat d'une fonctionnement à
la fois de la police surarmés et d'une
culture de l'immunité qui est très
fortement ancrée aux états unis et qui
ne dépend pas que du président il y ait
un changement structurel qui devrait
s'opérer qui peut peut-être se perd et
on voit qu'il ya des changements par
exemple sur la la peine de mort les
etats unis sont en train d'avancer vers
de réflexion de la peine de mort
peut-être que ces mouvements très fort
qui demande des réformes de la police
on va avoir un impact et
l'administration que les soutenir mais
dans les fêtes on a vu ça avec obama
obama
chaque tuerie dans les écoles par
exemple faisait de très beaux discours
mais il était bloqué par un système
politique qui fonctionnait à l'encontre
du contrôle des armes
alors il ya le procès des racks chauvin
sur fond justement de ce procès qu'est
ce qui peut se passer dans les semaines
à venir à après les drames que les états
unis viennent de connaître alors ce qui
est intéressant quand même dans ce
procès c'est que pour la première fois
on a vu certains membres de la police se
désolidariser du policier meurtrier et
l'éclair puisqu'il ya énormément de
vidéos qui ont été faites qui sa grille
d'un meurtre puisqu'on a le genou du
policier appuyé sur la gorge des
trottoirs qui crie je ne peux pêche
plairait peut respirer
donc il ya les témoignages vidéos mais
aussi le début de réflexion qui commence
à passer par une partie de la police qui
a témoigné contre dingue chauvin donc
peut-être qu'il ya une évolution qui est
en train de d'émerger aux états unis
prise de conscience y compris au sein
des forces de police heure américaine
alors il ya une prise de conscience de
nos clubs parce que parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de manifestations maintenant
avant d'arriver à des résultats
tangibles pour faire le pour diminuer le
la circulation d'armes a récemment le
journaliste américain s'appelle tom
hagen hat a publié un article s'appelle
la capitale du massacre en parlant de la
circulation des armes aux états unis
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
historique très répandue et qui avait
des soutiens populaires important pas la
majorité afin qu'un mais des soutiens
populaires important au faire bouger les
choses c'est c'est quelque chose qui
peut qui est possible mais peut-être
qu'on le début d'une évolution
on est très très loin d'arriver
à une situation comme il en existe dans
d'autres pays démocratiques en europe de
l'ouest
merci beaucoup à vous pierre guerlain je
rappelle que vous êtes ancien professeur
de civilisation américaine apparaît 10